So we have to turn our sense of design and style. And we have to quantify what good code is. And I don't think this is going to necessarily be an easy problem. But I do think it's doable. I'll give you an example. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 299 recorded on August 12, 2026. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about code review in the age of AI.
所以我们必须转变我们的设计和风格感。并且我们必须将什么是好代码量化。我不认为这必然是一个容易的问题。但我确实认为这是可行的。我给你举个例。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 299 期，录制于 2026 年 8 月 12 日。我是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起聊聊人工智能时代的的代码审查。
and whether humans are still needed in the loop. Connor. What's up, buddy? Did you misspell your own name? Well, first of all, how's my audio quality? Your audio quality is very good. That's surprising. Wait, I got to get my headphones.
以及人类是否仍然需要留在循环中。康纳。怎么了，伙计？你把自己的名字拼错了？好吧，首先，我的音频质量怎么样？你的音频质量非常好。这挺让人惊讶的。等等，我得去拿我的耳机。
Okay. By good, I mean relative to my computer. Okay. Okay. All right. Now, I found one pair of headphones. I don't know where my other headphones are and my computer is, this thing's really on its last leg.
好的。说好，我是指相对于我的电脑而言。好吧。好吧。好了，现在，我找到了一副耳机。我不知道我的另一副耳机在哪里，而且我的电脑，这个东西真的快要撑不下去了。
It's, you know, it's 10 years old. I had been hoping to upgrade it three years ago when the new Nvidia laptop chip came out, but I've been waiting and waiting and waiting. Hopefully soon, I'll be able to get the RTX Spark laptop. I'm very excited about it. But, yeah, this thing barely works now. But okay, so you sent me an invitation that's Connor C-O-N-N-O-R.
你知道的，它已经10年了。我本来希望在三年前英伟达新的笔记本芯片出来时升级它，但我一直在等，等，等。希望很快我能买到 RTX Spark 笔记本电脑。我对此非常兴奋。但是，是的，这东西现在几乎不能用了。但是，好吧，所以你发给我的邀请函上是 Connor，拼写是 C-O-N-N-O-R。
I did. Yes, that is not how you spell your name. At least... You asked earlier, did I spell my name wrong? And I did not. So question, Bryce, what are the top three reasons? The name would be spelled wrong in my invite. Well, I suppose it's possible that this entire time I have been spelling your name wrong.
我是发了。是的，你的名字可不是那样拼的。至少……你刚才问我，我是不是把自己的名字拼错了？我并没有。所以有个问题，布莱斯，在我的邀请里名字会被拼错的前三个原因是什么？嗯，我想有可能是一直以来我都在把你的名字拼错。
And you have just never corrected me. No, it's definitely not it. My name is one end. It's the Irish spelling because I'm half Irish. So guess again? Because you can't type well today? Because your hands are busy? I can't type at all right now.
而你从来没有纠正过我。不，绝对不是这样。我的名字只有一个n。这是爱尔兰语的拼写，因为我有二分之一的爱尔兰血统。所以再猜一次？因为你今天打字不好？因为你的手很忙？我现在的确根本打不了字。
You're very hot. Indeed. Because you're running or you're doing some other activity. I'll take myself off camera for a second. Are you driving? I am driving, folks. It's an ADSP first. Road trip.
你很热。确实。因为你在跑步或者在做别的活动。我先把摄像头关一会儿。你在开车吗？各位，我正在开车。这是 ADSP 的第一次。公路旅行。
Why are you driving? Is this unexpected driving? Yeah, I was supposed to be back by now, but I've been running late all day long, and I was going to message you to say I'm going to be an hour late, so maybe we can just chat, and then we can record when I get home. but according to you, my audio is good. Will the recording be good? I don't know.
你为什么在开车？这是意料之外的开车吗？是的，我本该早就回来的，但我一整天都在迟到，我本打算给你发条消息说我要晚一个小时到，所以也许我们先聊聊，然后等我到家后再录制。但根据你的说法，我的音频很好。录音效果会好吗？我不知道。
I mean, now that I have my headphones in, it is less good, but... I say what we do. I mean, and man, oh, man is the traffic bad. So it's going to take me twice as long to get home. I may or may not be picking up Shima on the way home, but I'm supposed to be home at five. The meeting recording is supposed to end at 530. So we will definitely get one solid 30 minute episode once I get home.
我的意思是，既然我戴上了耳机，它就没那么好了，但……我来说说我们怎么做。而且，天哪，交通太糟糕了。所以我要花两倍的时间才能到回家。我回家的路上可能会也可能不会去接希玛，但我本该五点到家的。会议录制本该在五点半结束。所以等我到家后，我们肯定能完成实实在在地 30 分钟的单期节目。
So maybe we should treat that. And I have a really good topic, which I'm hesitant to start talking about now because I don't know how bad the audio quality is. And I want it to be good audio. So, I mean, we can just chat for the next 40 minutes. And maybe we can keep this as bonus. What do you call it? like recording. It's not footage,
所以也许我们应该这样处理。我有一个非常好的话题，但我现在有点犹豫要不要开始聊，因为我不知道音频质量有多糟糕。我希望音频效果能好一些。所以，我的意思是，我们可以在接下来的 40 分钟里随便聊聊。也许我们可以把这个作为额外的内容。你管这叫什么？就像录像一样，这不是素材，
but, you know, if it's good enough to use, we'll release this not as a bonus episode. If it's not good enough, maybe when I've got the kid and I can't record, this will be a backup.
但是，你知道的，如果质量好到可以使用，我们发布这个就不会作为额外的小剧场。如果质量不够好，也许当我带着孩子无法录音时，这就作为一个备份。
I was about, I was about to say like, you know, this is good prep for the listener because, my first thought was like, was like, oh,
我正要说，我正要说，你知道的，这对于听众来说是个很好的热身，因为，我的第一反应是，就像是，哦，
the baby has come early and Connor is like on his way to the hospital or waiting at the hospital or something. No, no, no. I mean, the baby could come any day now. I think Shima is 36 weeks or whatever full term is.
宝宝提前出生了，康纳正在去医院的路上，或者在医院等候什么的。不，不，不。我的意思是，宝宝随时都可能出生。我想希玛已经 36 周了，或者说足月是几周就是几周。
So now we're at the point where... Wait, why do you have to pick her up? Isn't she taking time off work before she's due? No, no. She's working right up until... My mom did the same thing. Yeah, yeah. It's...
所以现在我们到了这个地步……等等，你为什么要接她？她不是在预产期前就休假了吗？不，不。她一直工作到……我妈妈也这么做过。是的，是的。这是……
Although, no, yeah, she is working up. I think right up until, and apparently that actually I learned about something, there is both maternity leave and pregnancy leave, apparently in Canada for certain roles. And you have to take, at least for her job, as a public health doctor, you have to take the pregnancy leave before you take the maternity leave. But you can take the pregnancy leave as soon as the baby's born. So it's a bit of a misnomer. It's like optionally pregnancy leave.
虽然，不，是的，她确实在工作。我想一直工作到，显然我了解到了这一点，在加拿大某些职位上，既有产假，也有孕假。你必须休，至少对她的工作来说，作为一名公共卫生医生，你必须在休产假前休孕假。但你可以在宝宝出生后立即休孕假。所以这有点名不副实。就像是可选的孕假。
Anyways, the baby is still cooking in there. the oven. She was healthy. Remind me, remind me, did you have a name yet? We have two names, my favorite and her favorite. And her favorite is my second favorite. Wait, it's a boy, right? It's a boy, yeah.
无论如何，宝宝还在里面酝酿。在烤箱里。她很健康。提醒我一下，提醒我一下，你们起好名字了吗？我们有两个名字，我最喜欢的和她最喜欢的。而她最喜欢的排在我第二喜欢。等等，是个男孩，对吧？是个男孩，是的。
And my favorite, at one point was her second favorite, but she's kind of fallen out of love with it. So I'm pretty sure. It's not conclusive. Although, I mean, this episode might come out two days from now, and Schuma may or may not listen, but we haven't even discussed the finalization of this. But all indicators point towards we unofficially have a name picked that we actually haven't like finalized.
我最喜欢的名字，有一段时间是她第二喜欢的，但她现在有点不太喜欢了。所以我很确定。这还没有最终确定。虽然，我的意思是，这集节目可能在两天才后播出，希玛可能会也可能不会听，但我们甚至还没有讨论最终敲定这个。不过所有迹象都表明我们非正式地选定了一个名字，但我们实际上还没有最终确定。
But yeah, I really love my name, but, you know, it's a team effort. You know, all parties must contribute. Oh, man. So why were you late? Why were you late? What were you doing today that made you late? A lot of stuff. I was in the morning watching Odyssey in IMAX 70mm, which I bought the tickets for a month ago because it's sold out everywhere. The tickets in New York are like $500 or something.
但是，真的，我非常喜欢我的名字，不过，你知道的，这是一项团队合作。你知道的，各方都必须做出贡献。哦，天哪。所以你为什么迟到？你为什么迟到？你今天在做什么才让你迟到了？很多事情。我早上在看 IMAX 70毫米版的《奥德赛》，我一个月前就买好票了，因为到处都卖光了。纽约的票价大概要500美元左右或者别的什么。
You have dynamic pricing on IMAX theater tickets? Or is it like second? I think it's like the second market or something. That's just conjecture. That's just like something. heard. It could be wrong. I ended up going by myself because there were no
你们对 IMAX 电影票实行动态定价吗？还是说类似于二级市场？我觉得就像是二级市场之类的。那只是我的猜测。那只是我听来的。也可能是错的。我最后只能自己一个人去，因为没有
like basically in Canada Cineplex puts the theater tickets on sale a month out. And for that entire month, basically IMAX 70 millimeter of which there are two in the greater Toronto area are basically
基本上在加拿大，Cineplex 会提前一个月开售电影票。而且在整个月里，基本上 IMAX 70毫米版的电影票——大多伦多地区只有两家——基本上
also note except for the like the 11 a.m. and the I think like 3 p.m. shows. and even those, it's only like the bottom section with like one-seaters. And anyways, we actually considered driving
也完全买不到，除了上午11点和下午3点左右的场次。即使是那些场次，也只剩下那种只有单人座的底部区域了。不管怎样，我们当时甚至考虑开车
to Rochester, New York, because they had tickets available for the 1045 showing. Anyways, so that was in the morning, and then that, ooh, I ended up just seeing, oh, what is that?
去纽约罗切斯特，因为他们有10点45分场次的票。不管怎样，那是早上发生的，然后那个，噢，我最后只是看到了，噢，那是什么？
It was a hawk. It was a hawk. I knew it. I knew it was a bird, folks. Yeah. I called it. It might have been a red tail. But it might have been something else.
那是一只鹰。那是一只鹰。我就知道。我就知道那是只鸟，伙计们。是的。我猜对了。那可能是一只红尾鹰。但也有可能是别的什么。
It might have been a broad-winged hawk. I mean, you know, you got to keep your eyes on the road. Or at least that's what you should be doing. While recording a podcast and having a... I didn't realize that Ramona was home. And I just shouted that very loudly. And she just walked into the room. And she gave me a look.
它可能是一只宽翅鵟。我的意思是，你知道的，你得把注意力放在路上。或者至少这是你应该做的。在录播客的同时还……我没意识到雷莫娜在家。我刚才喊得很大声。她刚好走进房间。她看了我一眼。
And then she closed the door. Yeah. Oh, man. I am looking for an Odyssey ticket. I didn't want to see it. won't say anything now because I don't want to spoil it because I imagine many of our listeners have not seen it. Although, I guess maybe, because the thing is, it's really the IMAX 70 millimeter that are
然后她把门关上了。是的。哦，天哪。我正在找一张《奥德赛》的票。我本来不想看的。我现在什么都不会说，因为我不想剧透，我猜我们的很多听众还没看过。不过，我想也许，因为问题是，真正卖光的是 IMAX 70毫米版的票，
the ones that are like sold out because that's what the show or the movie was filmed for. Anyways, no spoilers, no reviews. Maybe in like, remind me around like November or Christmas time, at which point you have no excuse if you haven't seen it by then. And you'll have seen it by then and maybe we can do a Odyssey review. Anyways, then I had to run and then there was a meeting in the middle of that. And so, yeah, it's just been a crazy day.
因为那是这部秀或电影拍摄时所采用的格式。不管怎样，不剧透，不写影评。也许在大约11月或圣诞节左右提醒我一下，到了那个时候，如果你还没看过那就没有任何借口了。到时候你肯定已经看过了，也许我们可以做一期《奥德赛》的影评。不管怎样，我得赶快走，中间还有一个会议。所以，是的，这真是疯狂的一天。
And here we are now, recording on the way back home. What have you been up to? How's life? How's work? How's AI? There are tickets available. Maybe, yeah, maybe I'm on. I don't see it.
我们现在就在这里，在回家的路上录音。你最近在忙什么？生活怎么样？工作怎么样？人工智能怎么样？有票卖的。也许吧，也许我在。我没看。
Oh, man, I have, I just got back from Greece. Ramona and I were in Greece. She was doing this acting residency, and that was very cool. She got to, like, act in this play under the, like, right next to the Temple of Apollo and Corinth, like, at the Archaeological Society. It was very cool. And, like, they have to, the whole play is in Greek. So these, this theater company, like, they have, like, three weeks to, like, learn how to say everything in Greek. And, like, all the Greek people kept coming up to her.
噢，天哪，我刚从希腊回来。雷莫娜和我去了希腊。她在那里参加一个驻留驻地表演项目，非常酷。她甚至有机会在科林斯阿波罗神庙旁边的一部戏剧中表演，就在考古学会那里。非常酷。而且，他们必须，整部戏剧都是用希腊语进行的。所以这群戏剧演员只有大约三周时间来学习如何用希腊语说所有台词。而且，所有希腊当地人都跑来找她，
and being like, oh, your accent's perfect. Like, hot, like, I, you know, it's like talking to her in Greek and whatnot. And I'm just like, I could not. I could not do that. But we just got back. I was, I was in Greece. He was working from Greece.
对她说，噢，你的口音太完美了。就像，哇，我，你知道的，就像是用希腊语跟她聊天之类的。而我就觉得，我做不到。我做不到这一点。但我们刚回来。我当时，我当时在希腊。他在希腊工作。
It was very hot. There was no AC. I'm very glad to be back in America where there's air conditioning. But Greece was really lovely. And, man, I've just been, I've just been burning all the tokens. Burning all the tokens. The thing I've been trying to answer recently, has been what programming languages are most token efficient.
天气非常热。没有空调。我非常高兴能回到有空调的美洲。但希腊真的很可爱。而且，天哪，我一直在，我一直在狂烧 Token。狂烧 Token。我最近一直试图解答的问题是，哪些编程语言的 Token 效率最高。
And it's specifically for Cuda kernel writing. It's a mixed bag. It's a mixed bag. And I got to get some more data and do some more analysis before I know for sure. But yeah, I just been, I feel like I've never been busier. Just so many projects, so much to do. It's a little time to do it all. you know, I've been thinking more and more about how we're going to review all this stuff.
特别是针对 CUDA 内核编写。这是一个混合体。这是一个混合体。我需要收集更多数据并进行更多分析，才能完全确定。不过，是的，我只是觉得我从来没有这么忙过。有这么多的项目，有这么多的事情要做。做完这一切的时间有点少。你知道的，我越来越经常地思考我们将如何审查所有这些东西。
You know, in the past we did this thing where somebody would propose change to code base, and then a human would go and read the code, and we would all talk about the code, and we would iterate on the code. And it just increasingly seems to me like that process is not sustainable going forward. And so I've started thinking about what is the alternative. And I have come to the conclusion that all design, aesthetic, style, taste, and sense references that we have are only meaningful if they can be machine checkable. So we have to turn our sense of design and style. and we have to quantify what good code is.
你知道的，过去我们通常的做法是，有人提议对代码库进行更改，然后人类去阅读代码，大家一起讨论代码，并对代码进行迭代。在我看来，这种流程在未来越来越不可持续。所以我开始思考替代方案是什么。我得出的结论是，我们拥有的所有设计、审美、风格、品味和审美感觉的参考标准，只有在它们能够被机器校验时才有意义。所以我们必须转变我们的设计和风格感，我们必须将什么是好代码进行量化。
And I don't think this is going to necessarily be an easy problem. But I do think it's doable. I'll give you an example. Let's say that you get a PR that add some new feature to your code base, but it also introduces this utility function. And it turns out that there's another utility function already in the existing code base that you should really be using instead. At first glance, this seems like something that is hard to quantify, right?
我认为这不一定会是一个容易解决的问题。但我确实认为这是可行的。我给你举个例子。假设你收到一个 Pull Request，它为你的代码库添加了一些新功能，但它也引入了这个实用函数。结果发现，现有代码库中已经有了另一个你真正应该使用的实用函数。乍一看，这似乎是一个很难量化的东西，对吧？
Like the lesson here is like, don't reinvent yourself. Don't duplicate things, right? Like you don't want to have duplicated functionality within the code. So like how could we possibly make this something that we have a hard check for? Well, it turns out this one's actually kind of tractable. Because what you can do is you could build a tool that looks at the AST of the PR, of all the changes introduced by the PR, and compares all of the entities introduced by the PR against everything existing in the code base. And so, like, if you added some new function and that function was like 95% similar to an existing function in the code base, you could build a tool. that could detect that, and that could then leave a review comment saying,
这里的教训就像是，不要重复造轮子。不要重复做相同的事情，对吧？你肯定不希望代码中存在重复的功能。那么我们怎么可能把它变成一个我们可以进行硬校验的东西呢？好吧，事实证明这个其实是有点可行的。因为你可以做的是，构建一个工具来查看 PR 的 AST（抽象语法树），查看 PR 引入的所有更改，并将 PR 引入的所有实体与代码库中现有的所有内容进行比较。所以，如果你添加了一些新功能，而该功能与代码库中现有功能的相似度达到 95% 左右，你就可以构建一个工具，能够检测到这一点，然后就可以留下审阅评论说，
hey, did you consider using this function instead, this existing function? So for things like abstractions, genericity, don't repeat yourself, some of that stuff we could maybe build deterministic tools for. And I've just been wondering, like, how much of style and sense do, can we actually turn into something that's machine checkable? Because I think anything that we can't make machine checkable is not going to matter, because the only way to review code changes in the future
嘿，你有没有考虑过用这个函数来代替，这个现有的函数？所以对于抽象、泛型、不要重复自己（DRY）这些事情，其中有些部分我们或许可以建立确定性的工具来处理。我一直在想，到底有多少风格和语意，我们实际上可以将其转化为机器可检查的东西？因为我认为任何我们无法做到机器可检查的东西都是不重要的，因为将来审查代码变更的唯一方法
is going to be to have testing in place that's good enough that we trust that if the tests pass, that the code is good to merge, and that the tests have to not only test functionality, but also the quality of the code. What percentage of code do you think actually needs to be, like, reviewable in the future? Like, does code quality
将是拥有足够好的测试，好到我们信任只要测试通过，代码就可以安全合并，而且测试不仅要测试功能，还要测试代码的质量。你认为实际上有多少比例的代码在未来需要被人工审查？比如说，代码质量
from, like, a human point of view matter? Like, what, or so, the real question is, because I know, like, I think that, actually, I don't know if everyone can agree, that some percentage of code, like, doesn't need to be reviewed. So, like, what,
从人类的观点来看重要吗？比如说，或者说，真正的问题在于，因为我知道，呃，我认为，实际上，我不知道大家是否能达成一致，即某种比例的代码，呃，是不需要被审查的。所以，呃，什么样的人，
what code needs to be reviewed? I think, like, yeah, like, examples of code that doesn't need to be reviewed. If it's, like, something for, like, some, like, internal info project or some like script or something like that. Yeah, maybe it doesn't need to be reviewed. But for something that's like going into like, you know, a software application or like a library in particular or something like that, it's not that the code needs to be reviewed. It's never
什么代码需要被审查？我认为，是的，比如，不需要审查的代码的例子。如果它是像针对某种内部信息项目，或者某种脚本之类的事情。是的，也许它不需要被审查。但对于那些要进入某个软件应用程序，或者特别是某个库之类的事情，这不是代码需要被审查的问题。这从来都不是
been about the review of the code. It's about quality control. It's always been about just quality control and testing. And like there's nothing sacred about the review process. The, the reason that we do the reviews today is because we have not been able to automate the checking for quality. And if you think about it, there was a time when we did not have CI in this industry, where we did not have continuous testing, where if you, like, the only way to know whether the commit was good or not was like you would go and run manual testing. And like we think of that now as the dark ages. And I think in the future, we may think of the days of code review as being the Dark Ages 2. But I do think that, like, there, again, it's not about the review.
关于代码审查本身。这是关于质量控制的。这历来都只是关于质量控制和测试。代码审查过程并没有什么神圣不可侵犯的。我们今天之所以要做审查，是因为我们一直没能将质量检查自动化。如果你想一想，在这个行业里曾经有一段时间我们没有CI（持续集成），没有持续测试，如果你想知道一次提交是好是坏，唯一的办法就是去进行手动测试。现在我们把那段时期视为黑暗时代。我认为在未来，我们可能会把代码审查的时代看作是“黑暗时代2”。但我确实认为，同样地，这与审查无关，
It's about whether we can create systems that we are confident enough that the automated testing process is sufficient to ensure the quality of the product. And today, I think there are very few large, important, critical production code bases for which the automated validation is sufficient to allow agents to merge PRs without human review. And that is a problem that the industry needs to solve. that we do not every code base has some amount of unwritten, intangible
这关乎我们是否能够创建这样的系统：我们对自动化测试流程有足够的信心，足以确保产品的质量。而今天，我认为几乎没有什么大型、重要、关键的生产代码库，其自动化验证足以允许Agent在没有人工审查的情况下合并PR。这是行业需要解决的问题。我们没有……每个代码库都有一定数量未成文的、无形的
guidelines and practices and rules that exist largely for good reason and which if not followed might make the code difficult to maintain or introduce bugs in the future
准则、实践和规则，它们的存在在很大程度上是有充分理由的，如果不遵循这些准则，可能会使代码难以维护，或在未来引入Bug
or make the code difficult to audit or for difficult for humans to understand, which I do think human understandability is important. And I don't think that any code base today is in a place where it has sufficiently automated all of those rules and guidelines to a point where you could just let agents,
或者使代码难以审计，或者让人类难以理解。我确实认为人类的可理解性很重要。而且我认为当今没有任何一个代码库能够将所有这些规则和准则充分自动化到一个程度，让你能够直接放手让Agent——
if they pass this set of checks, you can let them commit. I don't know. I mean, maybe. You're like picturing a very still, I don't know, I feel like you're projecting, projecting the flaws of like human programming onto the future of like AI programming. And I have honestly over the last like month become more and more infuriated with the quality. And I am like I am omitting many, many expletives that my wife has heard about like how bad software is.
只要它们通过了这套检查，你就可以让它们提交。我不知道。我的意思是，也许吧。你好像还在设想一种非常平静的……我不知道，我感觉你在把人类编程的缺陷投射到人工智能编程的未来上。老实说，在过去的一个月里，我对软件质量越来越感到愤怒。我省去了很多我妻子听过的脏话，比如软件到底有多烂。
Like, like, we seem to think that like we talk about like, oh, AI, blah, blah, blah. It's not as good. Like, look at the state of the software industry. I have, I want to make this YouTube video that I just don't have time to make. That's called the worst software, like, ever written. And it is my Toyota phone app. It never works. It never works.
比如，我们好像觉得，我们在讨论什么“AI啊，巴拉巴拉”。它没那么好。看看软件行业的现状。我本来想做个YouTube视频，只是没时间做。那视频就叫“史上最烂软件”。那就是我的丰田手机App。它从来没正常工作过。从来没有。
Every single time you open the app, whatever you try to do and like the information that it provides you is stale. and like you have to open the app and you can't just close it right away you have to wait like you have to open it up close it maybe do that a couple times and like wait a minute or two every single time i click charge now it tells me failed to do that operation but it's always successful and uh and like so many times at least like four or five times a month it turns off my manual charging and like it's scheduled to start at seven PM and so like if that it get that gets turned off like the car doesn't get charged and then we it's like it's literally polluting the world this app is making me cause like use more gasoline like every once in a while the car just starts using gasoline like right now I'm on electric mode and the thing about the the Toyota Prius 2025 model that I have it's like as long as you have a battery you can keep it in EV mode I found though that if you go below minus 13 Celsius it turns off the ability to be electric irritate but whatever, but then sometimes it just like turns on for no reason. Anyways, like, we did this. We did this and like AI is so good. Codex GPT 5.6, like, if you ask it to go and diagnose all the bugs in some program, it'll, it goes and finds so much stuff and that's stuff that humans wrote. And anyway, so I just like, I just have started to notice like how bad all software is. There's not like a single piece of software.
每次你打开App，无论你想做什么，它提供的信息都是过时的。你必须打开App，而且不能马上关闭，你得等一下——你得打开它、关闭它，可能得重复好几次，每次都要等上一两分钟。每次我点击“立即充电”，它都告诉我“操作失败”，但实际上总是成功的。而且，呃，每个月至少有四五次，它会关掉我的手动充电，它原本设定在晚上7点开始充电，所以如果这个被关掉了，车就充不上电，然后我们就……这简直是在污染地球！这个App逼得我多用了汽油。每隔一段时间，车子就会开始消耗汽油——就像现在，我明明开的是纯电动模式，而我这辆2025款丰田普锐斯的特点是，只要你还有电量，你就可以一直保持在EV模式。不过我发现，如果气温降到零下13摄氏度以下，它就会自动关闭纯电动功能，真烦人，但随它去吧。然而有时候，它又会无缘无故地自己启动。总之，我们做到了这一点。我们做到了，而且AI明明那么厉害。像Codex、GPT 5.6，如果你让它去诊断某个程序中的所有Bug，它会找出一大堆问题，而这些全都是人类写出来的代码。不管怎样，我只是开始注意到所有软件到底有多烂。没有哪怕一个软件
or like technology that I use that just constantly works well and that like I either don't notice because it works so well or like I'm happy because I'm just like, wow, this is a really great piece of software. Like all of it's terrible to some extent. And anyway, so when I hear you talking about like, oh, you know, we gotta figure out how to do this and that. I'm just like, I will give you an example.
或者我使用的技术能够始终如一地完美工作，以至于要么我因为它们太好用了而忽略了它，要么我感到高兴，因为我会想：“哇，这真的是一款非常棒的软件。”所有的软件在某种程度上都很糟糕。总之，当我听你在那儿说“哦，你知道，我们得弄清楚怎么做这个那个”的时候，我就觉得……我给你举个例子。
I will give you an example. Right now. Good software? Of good software? Right now, right now the Kuda core compute library is repo has 300 open PRs and 1.6K open issues. And I think if we merged all of the PRs that were currently passing tests, I think it would break, it would be chaos. Like if you took all of the PRs that were currently passing the test and you merged them all, I am sure that bad things would happen.
我马上给你举个例子。好软件？说好软件？现在，CUDA核心计算库的代码库里有300个未合并的PR和1.6K个未解决的Issue。我想，如果我们把目前所有通过测试的PR都合并进去，我估计它会崩溃，那将是一场灾难。如果你把当前所有通过测试的PR全部合并，我敢肯定会有坏事发生。
And that to me means that, like, we're not ready. Like, we don't have sufficient, we have not sufficiently spec or validated the functionality that this software is supposed to provide. And likewise, I think if you told an agent, go fix every one of these 1.6K issues and close every, like, close every issue by, like, merging commits to the, merging commits or close them if they're invalid. or whatever, again, I think it would be chaos. Would you disagree? I disagree. I disagree. I think it's not as easy as just sending 5.6 soul off to fix everything. But I think that like if you, whether just individually or as a team, like guided it because
在我看来，这意味着我们还没准备好。我们还没有充分规范或验证这些软件本应提供的功能。同样地，如果你告诉一个Agent：“去修复这1.6K个Issue中的每一个，并通过合并提交或者在它们无效时关闭它们来解决每一个Issue……”或者诸如此类的话，我认为这又会是一场灾难。你不同意吗？我不同意。我不同意。我认为事情没那么简单，直接派5.6模型去把一切都修好就行了。但我认为，如果你无论是单兵作战还是作为团队，去引导它，因为
some of these things, I guarantee you are going to conflict. And so like it's something that like a decision needs to be made. If you gave the AI direction saying, like, listen, this is our overarching goals. If you end up seeing two things that are in conflict with each other, like make a decision as like a project manager. Honestly, I think it might be, it might do just as well as humans. But like, and I'm not saying that it would get it on one shot, but if you set this thing up in a loop and like told it what the existing infrastructure is and said, hey, like add whatever
我向你保证，其中一些事情必然会产生冲突。所以这就需要做决定。如果你给AI下达指令说：“听着，这是我们的总体目标。如果你最终发现两件事情彼此冲突，就像项目经理那样做出决定。”老实说，我认为它做得不会比人类差。我并不是说它能一步到位，但如果你把这个东西设置在一个循环中，告诉它现有的基础设施是什么，然后说：“嘿，添加任何
more infrastructure. I honestly, I think it would succeed. And I'm of the opinion that these models programmatically are better than like almost all humans in like every domain. But do you think, do you think if we merged all 300 of these PRs, do you not think that it would introduce instabilities into the code base that over time would make it unmantainable? Well, I mean, if you ask the AI to merge all 300 of these things, it wouldn't just do it all at once. I like, you know, you have to give it, you know, a command that says, you know, priority, prioritize these in terms of like some goal, minimizing the conflicts, blah, blah, and like, you know, I honestly, I think I think it could happen.
更多的基础设施。”老实说，我认为它会成功的。而且我的观点是，这些模型在编程方面几乎在每个领域都比几乎所有人类都要优秀。但你觉得，如果我们合并这全部300个PR，你不觉得这会在代码库中引入不稳定因素，导致它随着时间推移变得无法维护吗？嗯，我的意思是，如果你让AI合并这300个东西，它不会一下子全部做完。我觉得，你知道的，你得给它一个指令，比如，设定优先级，根据某种目标进行排序，尽量减少冲突，巴拉巴拉，然后，你知道的，老实说，我觉得这完全行得通。
You know, you need to give it the right parameters. The real question is, do you think that the current tests are sufficient? Look, it'll add tests if they're not sufficient. I don't think that while I agree that AI is a great tool. not think that it is at the point where we could let it formulate the, like, I don't think it's at the point where we could let it wholesale manage the development of software like CCCL. Yeah, I don't know.
你知道的，你需要给它正确的参数。真正的问题是，你觉得现有的测试足够吗？听着，如果不够，它会自己添加测试的。我不认为——虽然我同意AI是一个伟大的工具，但我并不认为它已经达到了我们可以让它制定……就像，我不认为它已经达到了我们可以让它全盘管理像CCCL这样的软件开发的程度。好吧，我不知道。
I think we would have to codify more, I think we would, I think humans would need to codify more validation specs and requirements. before that could happen. Why does the human need to do it? Because I do not think that current models have sufficient judgment to do so. While they may be good at writing code, they don't always, like when I have a model do a task, its first instinct about how to go about doing it is wrong frequently enough that I would not want to entirely turn over all responsibility for a large production code to it.
我想我们必须编写更多的规范，我认为，人类需要编写更多的验证规范和要求，然后才能实现这一点。为什么需要人类来做这件事？因为我认为当前的模型没有足够的判断力来做到这一点。虽然它们可能擅长编写代码，但它们并不总是——比如当让模型完成一项任务时，它关于如何着手的第一个直觉经常是错的，以至于我不想把大型生产代码的所有责任完全交托给它。
What are you using? Are you using Opus 4.8, 5.8? Any model, 5.6 soul or any frontier model? I don't know. Yours and my experience is, I mean, I'm, yeah. But the topic that we're going to talk about next has to do with, like, my existential like what do you call it? Midlife, not midlife crisis, but just the, I did a point of like...
你在用什么？你在用 Opus 4.8、5.8 吗？随便什么模型，5.6 soul 还是任何前沿模型？我不知道。你我的经验是，我是说，我，是的。但我们接下来要谈论的话题与我的存在主义——你叫它什么？中年危机，不是中年危机，而是一个转折点，我达到了某种...
I do think our experiences are very different here, and I do wonder if it's that we're working on different things. Like, I have been working on getting the agent to merge, to merge the histocash algorithm into CCCL, and like, GBT 5.6 sole, its first PR attempt, it used the completely wrong approach for the tuning policies. Like instead of adding a parameterized tuning policy that would parameterize, that would allow you to customize the tunings for each different GPU architecture, which any human engineer working on the project would know that that's what you're supposed to do,
我确实觉得我们在这方面的经验非常不同，我确实在想这是否是因为我们在做不同的事情。比如，我一直在致力于让智能体将 histocash 算法合并到 CCCL 中，就像 GPT 5.6 soul 一样，它的第一个 PR 尝试，对调优策略完全使用了错误的方法。它没有添加一个参数化的调优策略（该策略可以针对每个不同的 GPU 架构自定义调优参数，任何在这个项目上工作的专业人类工程师都知道这才是应该做的），
it just hard-coded in many places the constants for the architecture that it was tuned for. And I had to tell it that, no, you need to follow the existing design patterns. And I frequently, almost always the first shot of a design that it gives me as flaws that I need to give it feedback on. Is your experience not been that you frequently have to give it feedback? or is your experience that it always gets things right on the first try? Or rather, has your experience been that you are able to set up a loop and that with a very high likelihood on the first time that you do the loop, that it gets things exactly the way that you want it?
而是在许多地方直接硬编码了它所调优的架构常量。我不得不告诉它，不，你需要遵循现有的设计模式。而且我经常——几乎总是——它给我的设计的第一版都有缺陷，我需要给它提供反馈。难道你的经验不是你经常需要给它提供反馈吗？还是说你的经验是它在第一次尝试时总是完全正确的？或者更准确地说，你的经验是你能设置一个循环，并且在第一次进行这个循环时，它极有可能会完全按照你想要的方式来实现？
Well, I'll dodge your question and answer it after I ask you a question, why are humans able to do that correctly and not the agent? because my guess is that it's, I don't know if tribal knowledge is politically incorrect, but it's like it's written, it's knowledge that's not written down. And so how's the agent's supposed to know about it? So that's like that's another human flaw. Like, why isn't that document? Connor, but that's what I'm, that's why I'm saying.
好吧，我回避你的问题，并在我向你提出一个问题后回答它：为什么人类能够正确地做到这一点而智能体不能？因为我的猜测是，我不知道“部落知识”这个词是否在政治上不正确，但它就像是——它是没有被写下来的知识。那么智能体怎么会知道呢？所以这就像是另一个人类的缺陷。比如，为什么没有被记录下来？康纳，但这就是我所说，这就是我说的原因。
That's why I said that we need to turn all of our design sense in guidelines and rules into machine checkable metrics, because that's even better than writing it down. Sure, we could just document all of it in the codebase, but if we instead figure out how to distill the design principles into something that can be machine checked, then it's just a part of CI. Well, I mean, that's the thing is like...
这就是为什么我说我们需要将所有的设计感、准则和规则转化为机器可检查的指标，因为这甚至比把它写下来还要好。当然，我们可以把它全部记录在代码库中，但如果我们转而找出如何将设计原则提炼为可由机器检查的东西，那么它就会成为 CI 的一部分。我的意思是，问题在于……
It's something that we can check deterministically. What you're saying is like machine-reaching. to me is just like it's just a cop it like that should be documented anyways like having something that's not written down that needs to be like human to human like verbally communicated that's like that's a flaw with the process right that's a first step but i think even if you wrote everything down i think agents would still get some things wrong and that's why you need to have machine checkable tests for these things yeah i would i would i would say that like honestly Everything that, like, make the difficult to the agents to, like, do things right are just, like, literally flaws of, like, the human process and that if we were better at, you know, writing down and documenting, et cetera, et cetera, that, like, the agents, the agents are would be totally able to, and I just think actually that is AI.
这是我们可以用确定性方法检查的东西。你所说的机器检查对民来说就像是——这只是一种借口，不管怎样它都应该被记录下来——有些东西没有写下来，需要像人与人之间那样口头交流，这本身就是流程上的一个缺陷，对吧？那是第一步，但我认为即使你把所有东西都写下来，我认为智能体仍然会犯一些错误，这就是为什么你需要为这些事情准备机器可检查的测试。是的，我会说，老实说，所有让智能体难以把事情做对的因素，实际上字面上就是人类流程中的缺陷。如果我们更擅长写下来、记录等等，那么智能体完全能够做到，而且我实际上认为这就是 AI。
Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on. Are you claiming that, that agents do not make a mistake? No, I'm not claiming that. I'm claiming, though, that they're better than humans, basically, at every aspect. If agents, if agents make mistakes, how are we going to check? How are we going to catch those mistakes? With, like, basically looping systems that monitor logs and, like, exception catches and stuff. And so they're just, like, self-healing.
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你是在断言智能体不会犯错吗？不，我不是这个意思。不过，我在断言它们在各个方面基本上都比人类更好。如果智能体犯了错误，我们该怎么检查？我们该如何捕捉这些错误？基本上是通过监控日志和异常捕获之类的循环系统。所以它们只是会自我修复。
Like, anytime there's some problem, they are able to, like, self-correct because they can monitor that something's gone wrong. And so, like, you, you... How am I going to, how will I know that a PR should be merged to CCCO? How, sorry, ask that question again? How should I decide whether a PR should be merged to the Kuta Core compute libraries? I mean, well, in an ideal world, you have like a bunch of automatic CI and GitHub action checks that, like, when they're all green, it's all good. But that is what I am saying.
比如，任何时候出现问题，它们都能够自我纠正，因为它们可以监控到出错了。所以，你，你……我该如何，我怎么知道一个 PR 是否应该被合并到 CCCL？怎么——抱歉，再问一遍那个问题？我应该如何决定是否应该将一个 PR 合并到 CUDA 核心计算库中？我的意思是，在一个理想的世界里，你会有一堆自动的 CI 和 GitHub Action 检查，当它们全部通过时，一切就都好了。但这就是我所说的。
What I am saying is that today, that is not sufficient. People have to do this code review process where they read every line. And the reason for that is because we have not sufficiently automated in CI, all of the things, the design sensibilities, et cetera, that we care about. And that is why people are still doing code review, because the CI process is not sufficient. Yeah, I see what you mean. Yeah, and I guess my meta point, or is it a meta point,
我想说的是，在今天，这还不够。人们必须进行代码审查流程，阅读每一行代码。原因在于，我们还没有在 CI 中充分自动化所有我们关心的设计理念等。这就是为什么人们仍在进行代码 review，因为 CI 流程还不够充分。是的，我明白你的意思。是的，我想我的元观点，或者说这是一个元观点？
just a regular point? Is that like the AI would have set that stuff up from the get-go, you know? No, because I think that some of those things, some of those things require substantial research and innovation, which, yes, we can do with AI, but they require substantial research and innovation that has not been done yet in our industry. My underlying premise is that we must replace the manual code review.
还是只是一个普通的观点？我的意思是 AI 本可以在一开始就把那些东西都设置好，你知道吗？不，因为我认为其中一些事情需要大量的研究和创新，是的，我们可以用 AI 来做到这一点，但它们需要大量尚未在我们行业中完成的研究和创新。我的核心前提是，我们必须取代人工代码审查。
We must take the humans out of the loop. I mean, I'm totally with you there. I just, I think we think we're at like different points on the curve. Yeah, but I don't see, I do not think there are large important projects today that have the human entirely out of the loop. Let me make it more tractable. I do not think that there are large software projects that have been around for more than five years that are all. automatically accepting, like, any AI PR without human review because they have so much confidence in their testing system. Yeah, but that's because five years ago, like, it was pre-AI.
我们必须把人类从循环中抽离出来。我的意思是，我完全赞同你的观点。我只是觉得我们处于曲线上的不同点。是的，但我看不出，我认为今天没有什么大型重要项目能够完全将人类从循环中抽离出来。让我把它说得更具体一点。我认为不存在任何已经存在了五年以上的、能够完全自动接受任何 AI 提交的 PR 且不需要人工审查的大型软件项目，因为它们对自己的测试系统有那么高的信心。是的，但那是因为五年前，它还是前 AI 时代的。
Like, that's like, you know, I promise you that there are companies out there that are, like, fully AI driven. We're like AI from the ground up, you know, sure, are they massive software or, like, codebases? Like, well, probably not because they only have started in the last, you know, two or three years, but, um, but I think, I think many of them still have humans in the loop at some point in the review process. I'm sure, I don't know if I agree with many. If you look at I'm sure like, well, I don't know. We'd have to do some kind of survey, but like, can you, can you, let's, you as homework, your homework is to find an example of an open source project that has the human completely out of the loop that has been around for more like more than a,
就像是，你知道的，我向你保证，有一些公司是完全由 AI 驱动的。就像从头到尾都是 AI，你知道的，当然，它们是大型软件或代码库吗？嗯，可能不是，因为它们只在过去的两三年里才开始，但是，但我认为其中许多公司在审查流程的某个阶段仍然有人类参与。我确信，我不知道我是否同意“许多”这个词。如果你看的话，我确信，好吧，我不知道。我们得做某种调查，但是，你能，你能，让我们这样，作为家庭作业，你的作业是找出一个开源项目的例子，它完全没有人类参与循环，并且已经存在了一年多，
more than two years at least I'll say. It has to be something that's been around for a while because that's the only way to understand like the software life cycle over time. I mean, what does that prove though?
至少两年吧，我这么说。它必须是存在了一段时间的项目，因为这是随着时间推移理解软件生命周期的唯一方法。我的意思是，那又证明了什么呢？
Like, you know? I don't know. I mean, what's open clause contribution policy? I think even OpenClaught, they still have a human that merges the PRs. I mean, is Clicking? a button really like a I mean one of my my array box thing like I click a button every a couple days that says merge but like I don't do anything other than that open claw has
就像，你知道的？我不知道。我的意思是，OpenClaw 的贡献政策是什么？我认为即使是 OpenClaw，他们仍然有人类来合并 PR。我的意思是，点击按钮真的算吗？我的意思是，就像我的那个 array box 项目一样，我每隔几天点击一次标有“合并”的按钮，但我除了那个什么都不做。OpenClaw 有
2.1k PR's open that tells me that their process is not entirely automated if the process was entirely automated there wouldn't be there would be maybe 100 open 2.1k PR's open means that there's like a backlog I mean I don't know I feel like this is like a What are we, what's the word? Like, fallacy or something is like, just because there's a human in the loop deciding what they want added or not added, it's not really like an actual human in the loop, like in terms of like coding and code review. Like you can make decisions at like a project level of the direction and the features and stuff like that.
2.1k 个未合并的 PR，这告诉我他们的流程并非完全自动化。如果流程完全自动化，就不会有——可能只有 100 个未合并的 PR。2.1k 个未合并的 PR 意味着存在积压。我的意思是，我不知道，我觉得这就像是一个——我们用的是什么词？谬误之类的，就是说，仅仅因为有一个人类在循环中决定他们想要添加什么或不添加什么，这并不真正算作是编码和代码审查意义上的真正有人类参与。你可以在项目层面的方向、功能等方面做出决策，
But like I'm talking about like the coding, the CI, the CD, all that stuff. I will again, I will challenge you to find me an example. of a large adopted open source project where they're accepting PRs without doing any code review today. By a human? Yeah, without any human code review today. All right. I guarantee you that there's a bunch. So whether they're two years old, whether they have 50,000 GitHub stars, I don't know about that.
但我是指编码、CI、CD 所有这些。我再次向你挑战，请给我找出一个例子：一个被广泛采用的开源项目，它们今天在不进行任何代码审查的情况下接受 PR。由人类进行的？对，今天没有任何人工代码审查。好吧。我向你保证有很多这样的项目。所以无论它们存在了两年，还是有 50,000 个 GitHub Star，我都不确定这一点。
I will. If you're challenging me just to find some open source GitHub projects that have like non-human. They have to be important projects that are used by a large, like a large base of users. I don't have a specific metric in mind. I will waive the specific two-year requirement, but it needs to be something that's used in production. All right. My wife's about to get in the car. so I don't know.
我会的。如果你是在向我发起挑战，让我去找一些有非人类的开源GitHub项目。它们必须是拥有庞大用户基础的重要项目。我心中没有具体的指标。我可以放弃具体的两年期限，但它必须是用于生产环境的东西。好吧。我妻子快要上车了。所以我不知道。
Well, she's not in the car yet. She's like 10 seconds away, and she may or may not want to be on the recording. We'll find out in a sec. I do have. Oh, sweetie. Would you like to be on the podcast? She shakes her head and says no.
好吧，她还没上车。她大概10秒钟就到，她可能想也可能不想被录音。我们一会儿就知道了。我确实有。哦，亲爱的。你想上播客吗？她摇摇头说不。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
请务必查看本期节目的shownotes，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP the podcast.com上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的一切事物的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你拥有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. Hi, Shima. How you doing? Hi, everybody. I'm pretty good. I'm pregnant.
那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是洒满信息碎片的混乱。嗨，希玛。你好吗？嗨，大家好。我挺好的。我怀孕了。
Yeah, I hear you're going to be due soon. Yep, I'm 35 weeks. So I'm almost any week now. Congratulations. Are you excited, scared? How does it feel being an almost mother? Oh, I'm really excited. Yeah, I can't wait. I'm super excited.
对，我听说你快要生了。是的，我已经怀孕35周了。所以我随时都可能生。恭喜。你感到兴奋、害怕吗？作为一个准妈妈感觉怎么样？哦，我真的很兴奋。是的，我等不及了。我超级兴奋。
The fetus moves a lot. We're very lucky. You refer to our baby as a fetus? You use our baby as a baby. Okay, our baby. Do not insult my future son by calling him a fetus. Well, I think he has a fetus. By definition? Yeah. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
胎儿动得很厉害。我们很幸运。你把我们的宝宝称为胎儿？你把我们的宝宝当作宝宝。好吧，我们的宝宝。不要叫他胎儿来侮辱我未来的儿子。嗯，我觉得他确实是个胎儿。按定义来说？是的。本期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。